As you may know, I love to shop for cardigans, skirts, and sandals this season. And when I do, I always make sure I get cash back from Rakuten. And it's not just clothing and shoes, you can get cash back from over 750 stores on electronics, travel, home decor, and more! Join for free at rakuten.ca. Start shopping and get your cash back sent to you by check or PayPal. Refer a friend and get Cha-ching for every friend you bring. $30 for you, $30 for them.
如你所知，我这个季节非常喜欢买开衫、半身裙和凉鞋。每当此时，我总是会通过乐天（Rakuten）来确保获得现金返还。而且不只是服装和鞋子，你还能从超过750家商店购买电子产品、旅游、家居装饰等商品时获得现金返还！立即免费加入 rakuten.ca。开始购物，并通过支票或 PayPal 领取你的现金返还。推荐好友，每带一位好友都能赚取奖励。你得30美元，他们也得30美元。
Get the Rakuten app or join at rakuten.ca. Rakuten.ca Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. On Wednesday, September 29, 1982, in the Illinois suburb of Arlington Heights,
下载乐天应用程序或在 rakuten.ca 加入。Rakuten.ca 我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用程序上或我们网站上的本集节目注释。1982年9月29日，星期三，在伊利诺伊州阿灵顿海茨的郊区，
27-year-old US postal worker Adam Janus felt the symptoms of a cold coming on and decided to take the day off from work. After picking up his two children from preschool, he visited a local jewel supermarket to purchase some pain relief medication. He chose a 50-capsule bottle of extra-strength Tylenol, an over-the-counter brand of paracetamol used to treat pain and fever. Adam returned home, ate lunch, then informed his wife he was going to take two Tylenol and lie down. When she went to check on him a short while later, she found Adam in bed convulsing.
27岁的美国邮政工人亚当·扬纳斯感到感冒症状袭来，决定请假一天。在从学前班接回两个孩子后，他去了当地的一家宝齐莱（Jewel）超级市场购买止痛药。他选择了一瓶50粒装的强力泰诺，这是一种用于治疗疼痛和发烧的非处方扑热息痛品牌。亚当回到家，吃过午饭，然后告诉妻子他要吃两粒泰诺然后躺一会儿。不久后，当她去查看他的情况时，发现亚当正躺在床上抽搐。
Paramedics were called, and by the time they arrived to the Janus House, Adam's state had worsened significantly. He was completely unresponsive, his pupils were fixed and dilated, his breathing laboured, and his blood pressure was alarmingly low. They rushed Adam to Northwest Community Hospital. He arrived in a comatose state and died in the emergency ward shortly thereafter at 3.15pm. The hospital's medical director, Dr Thomas Kim, declared Adam's cause of death as cardiac arrest, but was unsure what prompted the fatal condition in the otherwise young and healthy father. Dr Kim struggled to explain his uncertain diagnosis to grieving members of Adam's family,
人们叫了救护车，等他们赶到扬纳斯家时，亚当的情况已经明显恶化。他完全没有反应，瞳孔固定且散大，呼吸困难，血压低得惊人。他们将亚当紧急送往西北社区医院。他到达时处于昏迷状态，并在不久后的下午3点15分在急诊室去世。医院的医学总监托马斯·金博士宣布亚当的死因是心脏骤停，但不确定是什么原因导致了这个原本年轻健康的父亲出现这种致命状况。金博士艰难地向悲痛的亚当家人解释他那不确定的诊断，
and they left confused and devastated over their sudden loss. The group reconvened at Adam's Arlington Heights home to support his wife and children, and begin making funeral plans. Later that afternoon, Adam's 25-year-old younger brother, Stanley, was overcome with a grief-induced headache. He informed his wife, 19-year-old Theresa, and the couple went in search of a remedy, finding a full bottle of extra strength Tylenol on the kitchen counter. Stanley took two capsules, as did Theresa, as she also felt unwell. Minutes later, Stanley grasped his chest and collapsed to the floor. His eyes rolled back into his head as foam started pouring out of his mouth.
他们带着对突如其来的损失的困惑和悲痛离开了。众人重新聚集在亚当位于阿灵顿海茨的家中，安慰他的妻子和孩子，并开始筹备葬礼。那天下午晚些时候，亚当25岁的弟弟斯坦利因悲伤而头痛欲裂。他告诉了19岁的妻子特蕾莎，夫妻俩开始寻找解药，在厨房台面上发现了一整瓶强力泰诺。斯坦利服了两粒胶囊，特蕾莎也觉得身体不适，便同样服了两粒。几分钟后，斯坦利抓住胸口，瘫倒在地。他的双眼向上翻去，嘴里开始涌出白沫。
By the time the emergency services arrived near seven minutes later, Theresa had also fallen violently ill and started having a seizure. Stanley's pulse weakened and his breathing became heavy and laboured. Once Theresa's seizure subsided, her body stiffened and her breathing decreased to just four to five intakes per minute, before she stopped breathing on her own altogether. Back at Northwest Community Hospital, Dr. Thomas Kim was getting ready to leave work for the day when a nurse informed him that the Janus family were being brought back in. Dr. Kim presumed something must have happened to Adam's parents,
大约七分钟后，当紧急服务人员赶到时，特蕾莎也病得厉害，开始抽搐。斯坦利的脉搏变弱，呼吸变得沉重而艰难。特蕾莎的抽搐消退后，她的身体僵硬了，呼吸速度下降到每分钟仅四到五次，随后她彻底停止了自主呼吸。在西北社区医院，托马斯·金博士正准备下班回家，这时一名护士告诉他，扬纳斯一家被送回来了。金博士推测一定是亚当的父母出了什么事，
as they had been weak with the stress over the unexpected death of their son that afternoon. The nurse explained, no, it's his brother. Dr. Kim had met Stanley Janus earlier that day and was surprised to hear that the healthy six-foot-tall young man had suddenly fallen ill, presuming he must have fainted from grief. The nurse informed him, they are doing CPR and they are working on his wife too. The remaining members of the Janus family were placed under observation in hospital and even given their last rites in fear that they too would succumb to the unidentified illness that had struck Adam, Stanley and Theresa. Multiple explanations for the sickness were
因为他们那天下午一直因儿子意外去世的打击而虚弱不堪。护士解释说，不，是他的弟弟。金博士那天早些时候见过斯坦利·扬纳斯，听到这个健康的六英尺高的年轻男子突然病倒感到很惊讶，推测他一定是因为悲伤而晕倒了。护士通知他，他们正在做心肺复苏，也在抢救他的妻子。扬纳斯一家的其余成员被留院观察，甚至接受了临终祈祷，因为人们担心他们也会死于击垮亚当、斯坦利和特蕾莎的不明疾病。当时考虑了多种致病原因，
considered, including carbon monoxide poisoning and botulism, a rare and potentially fatal type of food poisoning, but both were investigated and ruled out. A search party consisting of an investigator for the Cook County Medical Examiner's Office, several local police officers and Arlington Heights nurse Helen Jensen were sent to Adam's quarantined house to look for possible contaminants. Nurse Jensen came across a bottle of Tylenol and recalled a conversation she had with Adam's grieving widow, who had explained that the last thing her husband did before falling unconscious was take some of the painkillers. Stanley and Theresa had reportedly taken some too. Suspecting that there was something wrong with the medication, Jensen confiscated the bottle and
包括一氧化碳中毒和肉毒杆菌中毒（一种罕见且可能致命的食物中毒），但这两者经调查后都被排除。由库克县法医办公室调查员、几名当地警察以及阿灵顿海茨护士海伦·延森组成搜查队被派往亚当被隔离的房子，寻找可能的污染物。延森护士偶然发现了一瓶泰诺，并想起她与亚当悲痛的遗孀的对话，遗孀曾解释说，她丈夫失去知觉前做的最后一件事就是吃了一些止痛药。据报道，斯坦利和特蕾莎也吃了一些。延森怀疑药物有问题，于是没收了药瓶，
the search party returned to the Northwest Community Hospital, where they learned Stanley Janus had since passed away. His wife, Theresa, was in an extremely critical and unstable condition. MUSIC That same night, Arlington Heights Fire Lieutenant Philip Capatelli received a phone call from his mother-in-law, Marge. The daughter of her friend, Gina Kellerman, had died suddenly that morning, and she sought an explanation for the tragedy. The Kellermans lived in the neighbouring suburb of Elk Grove Village, so Philip rang a fellow
搜查队返回西北社区医院，在那里他们得知斯坦利·扬纳斯已经去世。他的妻子特蕾莎情况极其危急且不稳定。音乐 当天晚上，阿灵顿海茨消防中队长菲利普·卡帕特利接到岳母玛吉打来的电话。她朋友吉娜·克勒曼的女儿那天早上突然去世了，她想为这场悲剧寻求一个解释。克勒曼一家住在邻近的埃尔克格罗夫村郊区，于是菲利普打电话给一位在当地工作的同行
firefighter who worked in the region, Richard Keyworth. Richard was aware of the incident, as earlier that day he made an impromptu visit to his fire station to collect some mail, and while there, overheard radio chatter about the peculiar death of 12-year-old Mary Kellerman. Hours earlier, as dawn broke at 6.30, a feverish Mary complained to her parents that she had a sore throat, runny nose, and headache. Dennis and Gina Kellerman decided to keep her home from school, and gave her one extra strength Tylenol to ease her discomfort.
消防员理查德·凯沃思。理查德知道这起事件，因为那天早些时候他临时去消防站取信，并在那里无意中听到无线电广播讨论12岁女孩玛丽·克勒曼离奇死亡的消息。几个小时前，即清晨6点30分，发烧的玛丽向父母抱怨她喉咙痛、流鼻涕和头痛。丹尼斯和吉娜·克勒曼决定让她在家休息不上学，并给了她一粒强力泰诺来缓解不适。
A short while later, Dennis heard a heavy thud emanate from the bathroom and went to investigate, finding his pajama-clad daughter unconscious on the floor. By the time paramedics arrived, Mary was in full cardiac arrest. She was rushed to Alexian Brothers Medical Centre, where she died at 9.56am. Heart attack, stroke, and an undiagnosed terminal condition were opted as possible causes of death, with more sinister speculation centred on the Kellerman family. An investigator interviewed Mary's father, and the police visited their home, but they uncovered nothing out of order.
不久之后，丹尼斯听到浴室传出一声沉闷的巨响，便去查看，发现身穿睡衣的女儿昏迷不倒在地上。救护车赶到时，玛丽已经完全心脏骤停。她被紧急送往阿莱克ian兄弟医疗中心，并于上午9点56分去世。心脏病发作、中风和未诊断出的绝症被选为可能的死因，而更阴险的猜测则集中在克勒曼一家身上。一名调查员采访了玛丽的父亲，警察也走访了他们的家，但他们没有发现任何异常。
The paramedics who treated Mary compiled a report which noted that the 12-year-old had taken Tylenol shortly before her collapse. Given the popularity of the painkiller, this detail didn't stand out as particularly meaningful. As firefighter Richard Keyworth relayed the circumstances of Mary's death to Philip Capatelli over the phone that night, Philip grew increasingly concerned. He had been monitoring a police radio throughout the day, and overheard reports of a string of bizarre tragedies in his Arlington Heights district, in which two brothers had died, and one of their wives was left in a critical condition.
治疗玛丽的急救人员编写了一份报告，其中指出这名12岁的女孩在昏迷前不久服用过泰诺。鉴于这种止痛药的普及，这个细节并没有显得特别有意义。当消防员理查德·凯沃思那天晚上在电话里向菲利普·卡帕特利转述玛丽的死因时，菲利普越来越感到担忧。他一整天都在监听警察无线电，并无意中听到报告称他的阿灵顿海茨辖区发生了一连串离奇悲剧，其中两名兄弟死亡，其中一人的妻子处于危急状态。
Philip noticed the Janus family's incident shared remarkable similarities to the sudden death of Mary Kellerman. As the two firefighters compared notes, Richard noticed the common feature in all four incidents, and remarked, this is a wild stab, but maybe it's Tylenol. Richard and Philip's theory reached the team at Northwest Community, who were already attributing the Janus' illness to the Tylenol, but had yet to connect Mary Kellerman to the case. The Tylenol seized from the two homes were compared. Both 50-pill bottles were the brand's extra strength variety, purchased from dual supermarkets
菲利普注意到扬纳斯一家的事件与玛丽·克勒曼的突然死亡有着惊人的相似之处。当两位消防员比对记录时，理查德注意到了这起四起事件的共同特征，并评论道：“这只是个大胆的猜测，但也许是泰诺。”理查德和菲利普的理论传到了西北社区的团队，他们已经将扬纳斯一家的病情归咎于泰诺，但尚未将玛丽·克勒曼与此案联系起来。从两个家庭没收的泰诺进行了比对。两瓶50粒装的药瓶都是该品牌的强力品种，购自芝加哥西郊的两家
within Chicago's western suburbs, and marked with batch number MC-2880. The remaining red and white capsules inside the bottles were poured out, releasing a strong odor of bitter almonds. The group immediately knew what this peculiar sign indicated, cyanide. When ingested, cyanide blocks the body's ability to absorb oxygen. Nausea, headache, and dizziness occur within minutes, and can be followed by the poison's telltale signs, shortness of breath, cherry red skin discoloration, and dramatic shifts in heart rate or blood pressure, progressing to cause seizures, coma, and death.
双子超级市场，并标有批号 MC-2880。瓶内剩余的红白相间的胶囊被倒出，散发出强烈的苦杏仁气味。大家立刻知道这个奇怪的迹象意味着什么：氰化物。摄入后，氰化物会阻断人体吸收氧气的功能。恶心、头痛和眩晕会在几分钟内出现，随后可能出现该毒药的明显标志：呼吸急促、樱桃红色的皮肤变色以及心率或血压的剧烈变化，进而导致抽搐、昏迷和死亡。
Book County's chief toxicologist, Michael Schaefer, conducted an immediate analysis of the Tylenol. He noticed several of the capsules were slightly discoloured and swollen in the red-coloured half. Furthermore, Tylenol powder was typically white, powdery, and did not dissolve in water. But the contents of these abnormal capsules were moist, grey, lumpy, crystalline, and completely soluble. Testing of this unknown substance confirmed it was potassium cyanide.
书县（注：原文Book County实为Cook County笔误）首席毒理学家迈克尔·谢弗对泰诺进行了紧急分析。他注意到有几粒胶囊颜色略有不同，红色的那一半有些肿胀。此外，泰诺粉末通常是白色、呈粉末状且不溶于水。但这些异常胶囊的内容物却是湿润的、灰色的、结块的、结晶的，并且完全可溶。对这种未知物质的测试证实它是氰化钾。
Six of the remaining capsules in the Kellerman bottle and four from Adam Janus' were laced with cyanide. Five to seven micrograms of the poison was fatal. The tainted capsules were filled with approximately 65mg, 10,000 times more than the amount required to kill the average person. Blood samples obtained from Mary Kellerman as well as Adam and Stanley Janus came back positive for a lethal amount of cyanide. Critically ill, Theresa Janus was also found to have the toxic salt in her system.
克勒曼药瓶中剩下的六粒胶囊和亚当·扬纳斯药瓶中的四粒胶囊都被掺入了氰化物。五到七微克的毒药就是致命的。被污染的胶囊中填充了大约65毫克，是杀死一个普通人所需剂量的10,000倍。从玛丽·克勒曼以及亚当和斯坦利·扬纳斯身上获取的血液样本检测结果均呈致命剂量的氰化物阳性。经发现，病情危急的特蕾莎·扬纳斯体内也含有这种有毒盐分。
At the time, Tylenol was the best-selling non-prescription pain reliever in the United States. The capsule variety was especially popular, as it was considered easier to swallow than the brand's tablet form. In 1982 alone, Tylenol learned its proprietor, Johnson & Johnson, approximately $400 million in sales, and claimed 37% of the over-the-counter pain relief market share. Tylenol made up one-fifth of the company's total product revenue, which included a range of medications, first aid supplies, baby products, and skincare.
当时，泰诺是美国最畅销的非处方止痛药。胶囊品种尤其受欢迎，因为它被认为比该品牌的片剂形式更容易吞咽。仅在1982年，泰诺就为其所有者强生公司带来了大约4亿美元的销售额，并占据了非处方止痛药市场37%的份额。泰诺占该公司总产品收入的五分之一，其中包括一系列药物、急救用品、婴儿用品和护肤品。
Johnson & Johnson were unaware of the emergency unfolding in Chicago's West until a local reporter contacted the company seeking comment on the deaths. A seven-member strategy team was established to deal with the crisis, maintaining that protecting the public was their primary concern, followed by salvaging their brand. Many officials met with detectives in the affected areas before launching an internal investigation to track down the cause of the contamination. In the meantime, they recalled the estimated 94,000 bottles of Tylenol in circulation from Batch MC 2880.
直到当地一名记者联系该公司寻求对这些死亡事件的评论，强生公司才意识到芝加哥西部正在发生紧急情况。成立了一个由七人组成的战略小组来处理这场危机，坚持认为保护公众是他们的首要任务，其次是挽救他们的品牌。许多官员在对受影响地区展开内部调查以追踪污染原因之前，先与当地的侦探会面了。与此同时，他们召回了流通中估计为94,000瓶批号为 MC 2880 的泰诺。
Widespread public panic, dubbed Tylenol hysteria, ensued. The medical examiner's office was bombarded with phone calls from worried locals who had recently taken the painkiller. While paramedics were equipped with cyanide antidote kits, as an influx of patients flooded regional hospitals reporting symptoms of poisoning. Local church groups and the Boy Scouts door-knocked through neighborhoods to help spread the word about the contamination, as police patrols cruised the streets announcing the threat over loudspeakers. The health department plastered the front doors of local homes with notices that read,
随之而来的是广泛的公众恐慌，被称为“泰诺歇斯底里”。法医办公室被最近服用过这种止痛药的担心当地居民的电话轰炸。与此同时，急救人员配备了氰化物解毒剂盒，大批患者涌入地区医院报告中毒症状。当地教会团体和童子军挨家挨户敲门，帮助传播有关污染的消息，而巡逻车则在街上巡逻，通过扩音器宣布这一威胁。卫生部门在当地家庭的前门贴上了告示，上面写着：
This message is to alert you about a contaminant that has been found in Tylenol products. We strongly urge you to stop using these products immediately. At Johnson & Johnson's Washington-based manufacturing plant, where Batch MC 2880 had originated, a quality control sample of the shipment's Tylenol powder was analyzed and came back clean. Company representatives assured the public they did not store cyanide at any of their factories and were certain that contamination occurred elsewhere. Some speculated the poisoning was an intentional act of sabotage by a vindictive employee, but this was quickly curtailed by the company, who explained the majority of Tylenol's production
此消息旨在提醒您注意在泰诺产品中发现的污染物。我们强烈敦促您立即停止使用这些产品。在强生公司位于华盛顿的制造厂（批号 MC 2880 的发源地），对该批次泰诺粉末的质量控制样本进行了分析，结果显示为清洁。公司代表向公众保证，他们的任何工厂都不储存氰化物，并确信污染发生其他地方。一些人猜测中毒是某个怀恨在心的员工蓄意破坏的行为，但这一说法很快被公司驳回，公司解释说泰诺的大多数生产
was carried out by machinery. As news of the Tylenol poisoning spread, police departments and hospital staff throughout Illinois initiated inquiries into recent sudden or suspicious deaths in their regions that might be linked. Two cases emerged, one in Elmhurst and the other in Winfield. At 4pm on Wednesday, September 29, office worker Mary McFarland complained to her colleagues at the Illinois Bell Phone Center of a tremendous headache. It wasn't unusual, the 31-year-old was a periodic migraine sufferer and as such carried
都是由机械完成的。随着泰诺中毒消息的传播，伊利诺伊州的警察局和医院工作人员开始对他们辖区内可能有关联的近期突然或可疑死亡事件展开调查。出现了两起案件，一起在埃姆赫斯特，另一起在温菲尔德。9月29日星期三下午4点，办公室职员玛丽·麦克法兰向她在伊利诺伊州贝尔电话中心的同事抱怨头痛得厉害。这并不罕见，这位31岁的女子间歇性地患有偏头痛，因此她的钱包里随身携带
a tin in her purse filled with a range of pain relief medication. Mary had stocked up her supply the day earlier, purchasing a 50-capsule bottle of extra-strength Tylenol from the Woolworth-Biven Dime Store in the Yorktown Shopping Center. When she felt a headache coming on at work, Mary disappeared into the break room to take some of her medicine. She re-emerged a short time later and informed her colleagues that she felt nauseous and dizzy before she collapsed against the table. Mary was rushed to Good Samaritan Hospital in nearby Downers Grove, where she died at
着一个铁盒，里面装满了各种止痛药。玛丽在前一天刚刚补充了库存，从约克敦购物中心的伍尔沃思-比文杂货店购买了一瓶50粒装的强力泰诺。当她感到头痛发作时，玛丽走进休息室吃了一些药。不久后她重新出现，告诉同事她感到恶心和头晕，随后便瘫倒在桌子旁。玛丽被紧急送往附近唐斯格罗夫的善良撒玛利亚人医院，并在
318 the following morning. Detectives later searched the tin in Mary McFarland's purse and found 10 Tylenol capsules amongst the assorted pills inside. Five of them contained cyanide. The bottle these pills had originated from was found in a medicine cabinet at her Elmhurst home, with only one of the remaining capsules inside testing positive for the poison. The contaminated bottle featured batch number 1910MD, which was manufactured in Johnson and Johnson's Texas-based plant.
第二天凌晨3点18分去世。侦探后来搜查了玛丽·麦克法兰钱包里的铁盒，在里面的各种药丸中发现了10粒泰诺胶囊。其中五粒含有氰化物。这些药丸原本所在的药瓶在她埃姆赫斯特的家中的药柜里被找到，里面剩下的一粒胶囊经检测呈毒物阳性。受污染的药瓶批号为 1910MD，产自强生公司位于德克萨斯州的工厂。
Around six hours after the death of Mary McFarland, 27-year-old Mary Reiner passed away at Central DuPage Hospital in Winfield. The mother had only just given birth to her fourth child, a baby boy, at the same hospital six days earlier. When Mary was discharged following the delivery, the hospital staff handed her a bag of items to help with her postpartum recovery, which contained a blister pack of eight extra-strength Tylenol capsules. On the afternoon of Wednesday, September 29, Mary consumed two of the capsules and was
在玛丽·麦克法兰死后大约六个小时，27岁的玛丽·赖纳在温菲尔德的中央杜佩奇医院去世。这位母亲六天前才刚刚在同一家医院生下她的第四个孩子，一个男婴。当玛丽分娩后出院时，医院工作人员交给她一袋物品以帮助她产后恢复，里面包含一板八粒装的强力泰诺胶囊。9月29日星期三下午，玛丽服用了两粒胶囊，
struck with nausea and dizziness. Her symptoms quickly worsened, and she died the next day. Four of the remaining six Tylenol capsules in her blister pack were found to contain cyanide. Initial media reports linked Mary Reiner's death to a bottle of regular-strength Tylenol she had purchased earlier that day. However, Scott Bartz, author of the Tylenol Mafia, concluded the capsules responsible were the extra-strength variety from the hospital blister pack.
随之感到恶心和头晕。她的症状迅速恶化，并于次日去世。经发现，她那板药中剩余的六粒泰诺胶囊中有四粒含有氰化物。最初的媒体报道将玛丽·赖纳的死与她当天早些时候购买的一瓶普通强度泰诺联系起来。然而，《泰诺黑手党》一书的作者斯科特·巴茨得出结论，导致死亡的胶囊是医院药板中的强力品种。
In his book, Bartz explained that when Mary returned home from the store with her Tylenol bottle, she swallowed two pills from the blister pack before emptying the remaining six into the regular-strength bottle. None of the regular-strength capsules contained cyanide, meaning the bottle had not been tampered with. How the blister pack came to be contaminated remained unclear. After learning of Mary Reiner's death, hospitals throughout the region destroyed the Tylenol in their possession, meaning the batch number these pills originated could not be accurately
巴茨在他的书中解释说，当玛丽拿着泰诺药瓶从商店回到家时，她吞下了药板里的两粒药丸，然后把剩下的六粒倒进了普通强度的瓶子里。普通强度的胶囊中没有一粒含有氰化物，这意味着该瓶没有被篡改。药板是如何受到污染的仍不清楚。在得知玛丽·赖纳的死讯后，整个地区的医院销毁了他们拥有的泰诺，这意味着这些药丸的原始批号无法准确
determined. As anticipated, blood samples taken from Mary McFarland and Mary Reiner came back positive for a lethal amount of cyanide, increasing the Tylenol death toll to five. The crisis claimed its sixth victim the following afternoon of Friday, October 1, when Teresa Janus was taken off life support after doctors had declared her completely brain-dead. At 5 p.m. that same afternoon, just over 20 miles away in Chicago's Old Town District, Carol Prince arrived at the high-rise apartment that belonged to her sister, 35-year-old United Airlines flight attendant, Paula.
确定。不出所料，从玛丽·麦克法兰和玛丽·赖纳身上提取的血液样本检测结果呈致死量的氰化物阳性，将泰诺死亡人数增加到五人。10月1日星期五下午晚些时候，危机迎来了第六名受害者：在医生宣布特蕾莎·扬纳斯完全脑死亡后，她被拔掉了生命维持系统。当天下午5点，在20多英里外的芝加哥老城区，卡洛尔·普林斯来到了她姐姐——35岁的联合航空空姐保拉的的高层公寓。
Carol held concerns about her sister, as her family had received a phone call from the airline informing them that Paula had failed to show up for work that day. Carol gained access to Paula's seventh floor apartment and found her lifeless body on the floor in the hallway. An open bottle of extra-strength Tylenol was sitting on the vanity in the nearby bathroom. Six of the capsules inside were found to contain cyanide. It was marked with batch number 1801MA, which also originated from Johnson & Johnson's Texas manufacturing plant.
卡洛尔对她的姐姐感到担忧，因为她的家人接到航空公司的电话，称保拉当天没有去上班。卡洛尔进入了保拉位于七楼的公寓，在过道的地板上发现了她冰冷的尸体。附近浴室的化妆台上放着一瓶打开的强力泰诺。里面有六粒胶囊被发现含有氰化物。它标有批号 1801MA，同样源自强生公司位于德克萨斯州的制造厂。
Paula Prince became the seventh victim of what would come to be known as the Chicago Tylenol murders, and the first in the city, meaning the contamination zone had expanded from the western suburbs into the heart of Chicago, putting millions of lives at risk. The search of Paula's apartment uncovered a Walgreens pharmacy receipt for the Tylenol dated the evening of Wednesday, September 29. Investigators determined that after touching down from an interstate flight at O'Hare International Airport at around 8 p.m., Paula drove towards her apartment, stopping at the Walgreens on the corner of West North Avenue and Northwell Street, where she purchased the Tylenol.
保拉·普林斯成为了后来被称为“芝加哥泰诺谋杀案”的第七名受害者，也是城中的第一名受害者，这意味着污染区已经从西郊扩展到芝加哥市中心，使数百万人的生命处于危险之中。对保拉公寓的搜查发现了一张沃尔格林药房购买泰诺的收据，日期为9月29日星期三晚上。调查人员确定，保拉从州际航班降落在奥黑尔国际机场后大约晚上8点驱车前往她的公寓，在西北大道和北韦尔街拐角处的沃尔格林药店停下，并在那里购买了泰诺。
Upon arriving home, Paula inadvertently took a poisoned capsule and collapsed beyond the bathroom door, remaining there for two days until her sister found her. The Walgreens store had no security cameras in the aisles to show how the cyanide-laced Tylenol ended up on the shelf, but there was one camera at the front of the store that was part of an automatic teller machine. This camera snapped a picture whenever someone withdrew cash, capturing an overview of the entire register area. At 9 p.m. on Wednesday, September 29, as a customer obtained money from the ATM, a photograph
到达家里后，保拉无意中吃了一粒有毒的胶囊，倒在浴室门外，在那里躺了两天直到被姐姐发现。沃尔格林商店的过道里没有安全摄像头来显示掺有氰化物的泰诺是如何上架的，但在商店正面有一个摄像头是自动取款机的一部分。每当有人取现金时，这个摄像头就会拍下一张照片，捕捉到整个收银台区域的全景。9月29日星期三晚上9点，当一名顾客从取款机取钱时，一张照片
was taken that happened to capture Paula Prince at the exact moment she purchased the Tylenol. The black and white photo showed her in her flight attendant's uniform, turning away from the register to look at a nearby magazine rack. It is noticed a Caucasian man standing several feet away, facing towards her. As he was positioned in the far right background of the image, the man's facial features were somewhat indistinct, but it was clear that he had a groomed beard, dark hair that was thinning on top, and was wearing a light-colored jacket, and possibly wide-rimmed spectacles. The chilling way in which the man appeared to be watching Paula led police to believe
被拍下，恰好捕捉到了保拉·普林斯购买泰诺的那一瞬间。这张黑白照片显示她穿着空姐制服，转身背对着收银台，看着附近的杂志架。人们注意到一个白人男子站在几英尺外，面向着她。由于他位于图像的远右侧背景中，男子的面部特征有些模糊，但很明显他留着修剪过的胡须，头顶有些秃顶的黑头发，穿着浅色夹克，可能戴着宽边眼镜。男子似乎在注视保拉的那种令人毛骨悚然的方式让警方相信
he could be the killer, intently observing his oblivious victim as she purchased the pills he had poisoned. As pills originating from multiple batches, manufacturing plants, and drugstores were now found to be poisoned, Johnson & Johnson announced a total nationwide recall of all Tylenol products, a decision that would cost the company $100 million. It was a huge task, given there was an estimated 31 million bottles in circulation, but the company vowed to destroy them all. They offered refunds and exchanges while halting all Tylenol production and advertising.
他可能是凶手，正全神贯注地观察着他用毒药谋害却一无所知的受害者在购买药丸。由于现在发现来自多个批次、制造厂和药店的药丸都有毒，强生公司宣布在全国范围内彻底召回所有泰诺产品，这一决定将使该公司损失1亿美元。这是一个巨大的任务，因为据估计有3100万瓶在流通中，但该公司发誓要将它们全部销毁。他们提供退款和换货服务，同时暂停所有泰诺的生产和广告。
450,000 Telex messages were sent to doctors' offices, hospitals, and trade groups to warn them of the potential dangers. As company executives appeared on news programs promising that Tylenol would not return to store shelves until the company had perfected tamper-proof packaging. Johnson & Johnson also offered a $100,000 reward for any information leading to the arrest or conviction of the person or persons responsible for the tampering. At the time, there was no protective sealing on any over-the-counter drug bottles which made tampering easy.
450,000条电传信息被发送到医生办公室、医院和贸易团体，警告他们潜在的危险。当公司高管出现在新闻节目中，承诺在公司完善防篡改包装之前，泰诺不会重返商店货架。强生公司还悬赏10万美元，征集任何有助于逮捕或定罪对篡改事件负责的人的信息。当时，所有非处方药瓶上都没有保护性密封，这使得篡改变得很容易。
Furthermore, capsule casings could be pulled apart to allow its contents to be replaced, with the two halves then reattached to appear untouched. Investigators noted that some of the poisoned capsules were put together more artfully than others, leading them to believe that either two or more people were involved, with some working more carefully than others, or that it was the work of just one person who didn't have much patience. Millions of pills were surrendered nationwide. In addition to the five bottles that led to the victim's death, three more bottles sold
此外，胶囊外壳可以被拉开，以便替换其内容物，然后将两半重新连接起来，看起来像未动过一样。调查人员指出，一些有毒的胶囊比其他胶囊制作得更巧妙，这让他们相信要么有两个人或更多人参与其中，其中一些人工作比其他人更仔细，要么是一个没有什么耐心的单干之作。全国各地交出了数百万粒药丸。除了导致受害者死亡的五瓶药外，在芝加哥地区售出的另外三瓶药也被发现遭到了污染。
in the Chicago area were found to have been poisoned. Two were handed in by customers, while the other was found in an Osco drugstore in the northwestern suburb of Schaumburg. The recall was a success, bringing an abrupt end to the crisis, and ensuring the death toll ended at seven. A task force comprised of more than 100 investigators from 15 agencies fronted inquiries into what was now regarded a mass murder investigation, with many officers working 15-20 hour shifts with no breaks to expedite efforts to find the culprit.
其中两瓶由顾客交出，另一瓶在绍姆堡西北郊区的一家奥斯科普（Osco）药店被发现。召回取得了成功，迅速结束了危机，并确保死亡人数停留在七人。一个由来自15个机构的100多名调查人员组成的特别工作组对现在被视为谋杀案的案件展开了调查，许多警官连续工作15-20小时不休息，以加快寻找罪魁祸首的工作。
In a surprise revelation, Johnson and Johnson disclosed that they had not been completely forthright earlier, admitting they did indeed store potassium cyanide at some of their factories. The substance was used in laboratory-based chemical testing, specifically to test povidone, the primary binder used to make Tylenol. Company officials insisted these labs were in a remote and separate location, far from the manufacturing sector, and were confident the foreign substance would have been detected if it was added during production. As only a few capsules per bottle were contaminated, and they had come from two separate batches
在一个令人惊讶的爆料中，强生公司透露他们之前并没有完全坦白，承认他们确实在部分工厂储存了氰化钾。该物质用于基于实验室的化学测试，特别是测试聚维酮（制造泰诺的主要粘合剂）。公司官员坚称，这些实验室位于偏远且独立的地点，远离制造区，并确信如果是在生产过程中添加的，这种外来物质会被检测出来。由于每瓶只有几粒胶囊被污染，且它们来自两个不同的批次
and factories, it seemed unlikely the poisoning was carried out during the manufacturing process. Nevertheless, investigators interviewed current and former staff, as well as their friends and families, but failed to identify any disgruntled suspects who had a deadly bandetta against the company. The contaminated Tylenol bottles were manufactured in Washington and Texas in August, before being dispersed nationwide to approximately 100 distributors, who then turned them over to around 11,000 retailers. As none of the victims knew one another, and the crisis was isolated to the Chicago area,
和工厂，因此中毒事件不太可能是在制造过程中进行的。尽管如此，调查人员采访了现任和前任员工以及他们的朋友和家人，但未能查出任何对该公司抱有致命敌意的怀恨在心的嫌疑人。受污染的泰诺瓶是8月份在华盛顿和德克萨斯州制造的，然后分发到全国大约100家分销商，再由他们转交给大约11,000家零售商。由于受害者彼此都不认识，且危机仅限于芝加哥地区，
it seemed likely that the tampering occurred after the Tylenol was shipped to Illinois, but before it was purchased by the victims. Employees at each of the stores that sold the poisoned pills were questioned, as were the janitors, delivery men, and maintenance personnel who had access to the stores, but no arrests were made. Many theories arose, including that the crimes were committed by one of Johnson & Johnson's competitors, or someone who stood the profit from investing in the safety packaging industry. Recently released prison inmates, psychiatric patients, and a Puerto Rican terrorist group
因此篡改极有可能发生在泰诺运往伊利诺伊州之后、但在被受害者购买之前。销售毒药的每家商店的员工都受到了盘问，可以接触到商店的看门人、送货员和维护人员也是如此，但没有逮捕任何人。出现了许多理论，包括这些罪行是由强生公司的某个竞争对手犯下的，或者是某个将从投资安全包装行业中获利的人犯下的。最近释放的囚犯、精神病患者和波多黎各恐怖分子
were also investigated as possible suspects. It was even speculated that the murderer only intended to kill one of the victims, but carried out the widespread contamination as a cover-up. Consequently, several of the victims' family members, friends, and associates were questioned, but they too were eventually cleared. Investigators considered whether someone might be seeking reprisal for the death of a loved one caused by a Tylenol overdose, and poured through a year's worth of local newspapers trying to find reports of such an incident.
也被作为可能的嫌疑人进行了调查。甚至有人猜测凶手只是想杀死其中一名受害者，但为了掩盖真相而进行了广泛的污染。因此，几位受害者的家属、朋友和同伴受到了盘问，但他们最终也被洗清了嫌疑。调查人员考虑是否有人在为因服用过量泰诺而死去的亲人寻求报复，并翻阅了一年的当地报纸，试图找到此类事件的报道。
According to uncover anything, they scanned the papers for something that could give significance to the date of the murders, but once again found nothing of interest. In the meantime, a police hotline rang off the hook as callers offered up thousands of leads, but the process of sifting through this information was hampered by pranksters, false confessions, and psychics detailing their dubious visions. It seemed as though the perpetrator was local to the Chicago area. After purchasing or shoplifting the bottles, they then returned to the stores to discreetly deposit them back on the shelves.
根据没有发现任何东西，他们浏览了报纸上可能赋予谋杀日期重要意义的内容，但再次没有发现任何有趣的东西。与此同时，警察热线电话响个不停，打来电话的人提供了成千上万条线索，但筛选这些信息的进程受到了恶作剧者、虚假供述和详细描述其可疑幻觉的灵媒的阻碍。凶手似乎是芝加哥本地人。在购买或顺手牵羊了这些瓶子后，他们又回到商店，秘密地将它们放回货架上。
No clear foreign fingerprints were isolated on any of the tampered bottles, indicating the killer may have worn gloves, which would have drawn attention given that the weather was warm, but no such sightings were reported. As it was a four-hour drive between the six affected stores, investigators believed the perpetrator distributed the bottles in a single day, likely the day before the poisonings commenced. This theory was supported by an incident reported by two Illinois police officers occurring in the early morning hours of Tuesday, September 28.
在任何被篡改的瓶子上都没有分离出明确的外来指纹，这表明凶手可能戴着手套，考虑到天气炎热，这会引起注意，但没有报告此类目击事件。由于六家受影响的商店之间有四个小时的车程，调查人员认为凶手在一天内分发了这些瓶子，很可能是在中毒开始的前一天。这一理论得到了两名伊利诺伊州警察在9月28日星期二清晨报告的一起事件的支持。
The pair arrived to the Howard Johnson's Motor Lodge and Restaurant in Elgin to grab a bite to eat, where, on the grassy median strip separating the parking lot from the adjacent road, they noticed two cardboard boxes marked with the words, extra-strength Tylenol capsules, and the name McNeil, the subsidiary company of Johnson & Johnson responsible for manufacturing Tylenol. Information displayed on the boxes indicated they contained 30 bottles of extra-strength Tylenol. One box was open, and only 24 bottles remained inside, two of which were open.
两人来到埃尔金的霍华德约翰逊汽车旅馆和餐厅吃点东西，在分隔停车场与相邻道路的草地中间隔离带上，他们注意到两个纸箱，上面印有“强力泰诺胶囊”字样，以及负责制造泰诺的强生公司子公司麦克尼尔（McNeil）的名字。箱子上显示的信息表明里面有30瓶强力泰诺。其中一个箱子是打开的，里面只剩下24瓶，其中两瓶是打开的。
A large quantity of white powder was scattered on the ground, along with hundreds of empty red and white capsule casings, some of which appeared to have been emptied and put back together. One officer handled the items, but as the cyanide poisonings had not yet occurred, the pair ultimately disregarded the find and went to get food as planned. As they ate, the officer who touched the items developed a headache, and his arm broke out in a painful rash and started swelling. When the pair returned to their vehicle, they stopped to re-examine the Tylenol boxes, and
地面上散落着大量白色粉末，还有数百个空的红白相间的胶囊外壳，其中一些似乎已被清空并重新组装。一名警官处理了这些物品，但由于氰化物中毒尚未发生，两人最终忽略了这一发现，按计划去吃东西了。在他们吃饭时，摸过这些物品的警官开始头痛，他的手臂长出痛苦的皮疹并开始肿胀。当两人返回车里时，他们停下来重新检查泰诺箱子，
at this time the second officer handled the items, and was soon overcome with a headache, laziness, and nausea. When the news of the Chicago Tylenol murders broke two days later, the officers reported their bizarre find to their superiors, and the Howard Johnson's motor lodge and restaurant parking lot was thoroughly searched. Little remained of the mysterious Tylenol boxes, and testing of what was recovered came back negative for cyanide. The first three memorial services for the Chicago Tylenol murders began on Saturday,
此时第二名警官处理了这些物品，不久便感到头痛、疲倦和恶心。两天后芝加哥泰诺谋杀案的消息爆发时，警官们向他们的上级报告了他们诡异的发现，霍华德约翰逊汽车旅馆和餐厅的停车场受到了彻底搜查。神秘的泰诺箱子几乎没有剩下什么，回收物的检测结果对氰化物呈阴性。芝加哥泰诺谋杀案的前三场追悼会于周六开始，
October 2. Around 150 mourners gathered at Queen of the Rosary Catholic Church in Elk Grove Village to farewell the youngest victim, 12-year-old Mary Kellerman. Her unexpected death had left her fellow seventh grade classmates and teachers in shock, and her grief-stricken mother had to be physically supported throughout the service. Less than ten miles away, Mary Reiner was farewelled by her loved ones in her childhood town Villa Park. Her husband Ed reminisced about their long and loving marriage, which had resulted in
10月2日。大约150名哀悼者聚集在埃尔克格罗夫村的玫瑰女王天主教堂，向最年轻的受害者——12岁的玛丽·克勒曼告别。她突如其来的死让同班七年级的同学们和老师们震惊不已，她悲痛欲绝的母亲在整个礼拜期间不得不被人搀扶。不到十英里外，玛丽·赖纳在她童年的小镇维拉帕克受到了亲人们的告别。她的丈夫埃德回忆起他们漫长而充满爱意的婚姻，
four children, including their newborn son. In the neighboring suburb of Elmhurst, Mary McFarland was remembered as an exceptional single mother to her two sons aged four and two. Friends and colleagues spoke of the positive impact she had on others, from her sense of humour to her work ethic, describing her as a good person and a good friend. The scale of loss was particularly immense for the Janus family, who had lost three members within days of one another. On Tuesday, October 5, a joint funeral service was held for Adam, Stanley and Theresa.
育有四个孩子，包括他们刚出生的儿子。在邻近的埃姆赫斯特郊区，玛丽·麦克法兰被人们铭记为她两个分别四岁和两岁的儿子的杰出单亲母亲。朋友和同事们谈到她对其他人的积极影响，从她的幽默感到她的职业道德，称她是一个好人和好朋友。对于在几天内失去三名成员的扬纳斯一家来说，损失的规模尤为巨大。10月5日星期二，为亚当、斯坦利和特蕾莎举行了联合葬礼。
Adam's four-year-old daughter kept her hand on her father's casket as the Catholic Archbishop of Chicago blessed all three victims and said, "'This is a great tragedy and loss. I wish as your pastor that I could relieve you of your burden of sorrow. But I can't.'" At the same time, a funeral was held for Paula Prince in her hometown of Omaha, Nebraska. Detectives staked out each of the funerals on the lookout for anyone uninvited, out of place or otherwise acting suspiciously.
当芝加哥天主教大主教祝福所有三名受害者并说：“这是一场巨大的悲剧和损失。作为你们的牧师，我希望我能解除你们的悲痛负担。但我不能”时，亚当四岁的女儿一直把手放在父亲的棺材上。与此同时，在家乡内布拉斯加州奥马哈，为保拉·普林斯举行了葬礼。侦探们在每场葬礼外布控，寻找任何不速之客、不合时宜或举止可疑的人。
Although several people caught their attention, nothing further developed. Time-lapse surveillance cameras were discreetly positioned around the cemeteries to monitor the gravesites 24 hours a day and remained in place until the device's internal mechanisms were frozen by the inbound cold weather. On Wednesday, October 6, eight days into the investigation, an envelope labelled Tylenol arrived at the Philadelphia-based office of Tylenol's manufacturer, McNeil Consumer Healthcare. Inside was a handwritten letter which read,
尽管几个人引起了他们的注意，但没有进一步的发展。延时监控摄像头被隐蔽地安置在墓地周围，24小时监控墓地，并一直保留到设备的内部机制被寒冷天气冻结为止。10月6日星期三，调查进入第八天，一个标有“泰诺”的信封到达了泰诺制造商麦克尼尔消费者医疗保健公司位于费城的办公室。里面是一封手写信，写道：
"'Gentlemen, as you can see, it is easy to place cyanide, both potassium and sodium, into capsules sitting on store shelves. And since the cyanide is inside the gelatin, it is easy to get buyers to swallow the bitter pill.'" Another beauty is that cyanide operates quickly. It takes so very little, and there will be no time to take countermeasures. If you don't mind the publicity of these little capsules, then do nothing. So far, I have spent less than $50, and it takes me less than 10 minutes per bottle.
“先生们，如你所见，把氰化物（包括钾和钠）放入商店货架上的胶囊里是很容易的。而且既然氰化物在明胶里面，就很容易让买家吞下这颗苦药。”另一个妙处是氰化物起效快。只需要一点点，就没有时间采取应对措施。如果你不在乎这些小胶囊带来的宣传，那就什么也别做。到目前为止，我花不到50美元，每瓶花不到10分钟。
If you want to stop the killing, then wire $1 million to bank account 8449597 at Continental Illinois Bank, Chicago. Don't attempt to involve the FBI or local Chicago authorities with this letter. A couple of phone calls by me will undo anything you can possibly do. The letter was immediately handed to the FBI, who worked to determine if the extortion attempt was just a con man capitalizing on the crimes, or legitimately the murderer responsible for the tamperings. They managed to lift fingerprints from the document and scratch away the envelope's
如果你想阻止这场杀戮，就电汇100万美元到芝加哥伊利诺伊大陆银行的8449597号银行账户。不要试图让联邦调查局或芝加哥当地当局介入这封信。我打几个电话就能撤销你可能做的任何事情。这封信立即被交给了联邦调查局，他们努力确定敲诈勒索是利用这些罪行的骗子，还是真正对篡改事件负责的凶手。他们设法从文件中提取了指纹，并刮掉了信封的
postmark, revealing a postage commerce number linked to a travel agency called Lakeside in Chicago. The U.S. Department of Justice directed the Continental Illinois Bank to turn over the financial records of the account mentioned in the letter. The account had been closed five months earlier and belonged to Frederick Miller McKayhee, an heir to the Miller Brewing Fortune. Investigators quickly established that Frederick was not responsible for penning the letter, and requested he list the names of anyone who would seek to ruin his reputation.
邮戳显示，一个邮资商业号码与芝加哥一家名为“湖畔”的旅行社有关。美国司法部指示伊利诺伊大陆银行交出一封信中提及账户的财务记录。该账户在五个月前已被注销，属于米勒酿酒财富的继承人弗雷德里克·米勒·麦凯希。调查人员很快证实，弗雷德里克并非该信件的执笔人，并要求他列出任何可能寻求毁掉他名誉的人的名单。
Frederick was the former owner of the now defunct Lakeside travel agency, and many of his ex-employees suspected he had diverted company funds to pay his own personal bills, which resulted in their final paychecks bouncing. Given the envelope used was from Frederick's former business, his list contained the names of four resentful staff members. One was Nancy Richardson. Former colleagues recalled that her husband, Robert, was somewhat eccentric and outspoken. During a wage claim hearing for the former Lakeside travel agency staff members, he
弗雷德里克是现已倒闭的湖畔旅行社的前老板，他的许多前雇员怀疑他挪用了公司资金来支付自己的个人账单，导致他们最后领到的薪水支票全部跳票。鉴于使用的信封来自弗雷德里克的旧企业，他的名单上包含了四名心怀不满的员工的名字。其中一人是南希·理查森。前同事回忆说，她的丈夫罗伯特有点古怪而且直言不讳。在前湖畔旅行社员工的工资索赔听证会上，他
had become particularly outraged when told there was nothing they could do about their unpaid wages, as there was no money for them to lay a claim against. Immediately after the hearing, he was witnessed having a heated argument with Frederick, and although others accepted the result and moved on, Robert continued going after Frederick. Others looking into Robert's background discovered he had a rapid, unhinged temper, and a reputation for holding grudges. They obtained handwriting samples from Robert's former employer, the first National Bank of Chicago where he had worked as a temp in numerous departments until early September, and they
显得格外愤怒，因为当时有人告诉他们，由于没有可供索赔的资金，他们对未付工资无能为力。听证会结束后不久，有人目睹他与弗雷德里克发生了一场激烈的争吵，尽管其他人接受了这个结果并继续生活，但罗伯特却一直纠缠着弗雷德里克不放。其他调查罗伯特背景的人发现他脾气暴躁、喜怒无常，并且有着记仇的名声。他们从罗伯特的前雇主——芝加哥第一国民银行获得了笔迹样本（他在那里作为临时工在多个部门工作到9月上旬），并且他们
discovered the handwriting was a match to the extortion letter sent to Johnson & Johnson. Police attempted to apprehend Robert, but he and his wife Nancy had since left their rundown apartment in Chicago's Northside for an unknown destination. A nationwide search commenced, and the police soon discovered that the names Robert and Nancy Richardson were aliases for James and Leanne Lewis. After being abandoned by his parents at age three, James Lewis was adopted by a childless couple. He grew up to become a troublesome child who was known to fly into rages.
发现该笔迹与寄给强生公司的勒索信吻合。警方试图逮捕罗伯特，但他和妻子南希已经离开了他们在芝加哥北区破旧的公寓，去向不明。一场全国范围的搜捕随即展开，警方不久便发现罗伯特和南希·理查森这两个名字是詹姆斯和利安妮·刘易斯的化名。三岁时被父母抛弃后，詹姆斯·刘易斯被一对没有孩子的夫妇收养。他在成长过程中成了一个令人头疼的孩子，以大发雷霆而闻名。
In one instance, he chased his mother with an axe, and in another, he faced an assault charge after breaking several of his father's ribs. At one point, Lewis was hospitalized and diagnosed with catatonic schizophrenia after overdosing on over-the-counter painkillers, but he later claimed his suicide attempt and violent behavior was simply a plan concocted by his family to avoid him being drafted to fight in the Vietnam War. Despite the dysfunction in his home life, Lewis enjoyed school and received good grades, later attending the University of Missouri where he met his future wife, Leanne.
有一次，他拿着斧头追赶母亲；还有一次，他在打断了父亲的几根肋骨后面临袭击指控。有一段时间，刘易斯在服用过量非处方止痛药后住院，被诊断为紧张型精神分裂症，但他后来声称，他的自杀未遂和暴力行为只是其家人精心策划的计划，目的是为了逃避被征召去参加越南战争。尽管家庭生活失调，刘易斯却很喜欢学校并取得了不错的成绩，后来就读于密苏里大学，在那里他遇到了未来的妻子利安妮。
The pair were staunchly devoted to one another and cultivated a comfortable life, both working as bookkeepers at a tax service until Lewis exploded at the business owner over a trivial matter, prompting the couple to leave. The pair then started their own taxation business in Kansas City, where 72-year-old Raymond West became their client. Raymond was a retired truck driver who lived a quiet life alone, tending to his garden and taking daily walks. On Monday, July 24, 1978, a missing person's report was filed on his behalf as a friend
两人坚定地互相对忠诚，并过上了舒适的生活，他们都在一家税务服务机构担任簿记员，直到刘易斯为了一件琐事向企业老板发火，促使这对夫妇离开了那里。随后，这对夫妇在堪萨斯城创办了自己的税务企业，72岁的雷蒙德·韦斯特成为了他们的客户。雷蒙德是一名退休卡车司机，过着平静的独居生活，平时打理花园，每天散步。1978年7月24日星期一，有人为他提交了一份失踪人口报告，因为一位朋友
noticed Raymond's car was in the garage of his home, but knocks to his front door were going unanswered. A note was found stuck in the door, written on James Lewis' business letterhead, it read, Ray is out of town until Thursday, for further, call Jim. Police forced their way into the home and found another note on the coffee table, which read, Please don't disturb until after 1pm, sleeping late, Raymond. Despite being signed off with the elderly man's name, it was not scrawled in his handwriting. On Saturday, August 14, police conducted a second search of Raymond's house.
注意到雷蒙德的车停在家里的车库里，但敲前门却无人应答。门上夹着一张便条，是用詹姆斯·刘易斯的业务信笺写的，上面写着：“雷外出至周四，如需进一步联系，请致电吉姆。”警方强行闯入家中，在咖啡桌上发现了另一张便条，上面写着：“下午1点前请勿打扰，雷蒙德正在睡懒觉。”尽管落款是这位老人的名字，但这并非他的笔迹。8月14日星期日，警方对雷蒙德的房子进行了第二次搜查。
A foul odor lingered inside, and they uncovered bloody bed sheets in the bedroom. In the basement was a bloodstained lawn chair along with a garbage bag containing Raymond's toupee and eyeglasses. In an upstairs room, officers noticed a foot-long stain running from the ceiling down the wall and made their way into the attic to determine its source. There, they found Raymond's decomposed and dismembered body, partially wrapped in sheets and garbage bags. His legs had been severed at the hip joint and placed alongside his head.
屋内弥漫着一股难闻的气味，他们在卧室里发现了带血的床单。地下室里有一把沾有血迹的草坪椅，还有一个垃圾袋，里面装着雷蒙德的假发和眼镜。在楼上的一个房间里，警官们注意到一条长达一英尺的污渍从天花板一直延伸到墙壁，于是他们前往阁楼查明其来源。在那里，他们发现了雷蒙德高度腐烂且被肢解的尸体，尸体被床单和垃圾袋部分包裹着。他的双腿在髋关节处被切断，并与头部摆放在一起。
Due to the state of his remains, a cause of death could not be established. It is discovered $5,000 had been withdrawn from Raymond's bank account and paid to James Lewis, who was promptly arrested. He maintained that the payment was a business expansion loan, which seemed unusual given Raymond was known to be tight with money. Lewis was released from police custody and permitted officers to search his home and vehicle, where they found 20 feet of knotted white rope, a garbage bag, and a black case containing papers and checks bearing Raymond's name.
由于遗体状态恶化，死因无法确定。据发现，雷蒙德的银行账户被取走了5,000美元，并支付给了詹姆斯·刘易斯，后者随即被捕。他坚称这笔款项是一笔业务扩张贷款，考虑到雷蒙德一向以吝啬闻名，这似乎很不寻常。刘易斯被警方释放，并允许警官搜查他的家和车辆，在那里他们找到了20英尺打结的白绳、一个垃圾袋以及一个装有写有雷蒙德名字的文件和支票的黑色箱子。
He was arrested again and charged with Raymond West's murder, a crime which he vehemently denied committing. In October 1979, days before his trial was set to begin, Lewis' defense counsel argued that the police had no probable cause to arrest their client in the first instance, and that he wasn't read his Miranda rights at the time. They also claimed that the original indictment was defective and was not worded correctly, as it omitted the term felonious. As Raymond's cause of death was unknown, his attorney had lined up a series of witnesses
他再次被捕并被控谋杀雷蒙德·韦斯特，他对此罪名坚决否认。1979年10月，即审判即将开始几天前，刘易斯的辩护律师辩称，警方最初逮捕他们的当事人时没有充分理由，且当时未宣读米ラン达警告（Miranda rights）。他们还声称原起诉书有缺陷且措辞不正确，因为它遗漏了“重罪”（felonious）一词。由于雷蒙德的死因不明，他的律师排了一系列证人
to testify the elderly man had high blood pressure and a potent medication regime, both of which may have been responsible. However, it didn't explain how Raymond's legs came to be severed from his body, and in a bizarre assertion, Lewis' attorney told the Chicago Reader newspaper, It's one thing to kill somebody, it's another thing to dismember them after they're dead. And whilst dismembering somebody after they're dead is repulsive and repugnant, it's not homicide. With nothing but circumstantial evidence to link Lewis to the crime, the case was dismissed
出庭作证，证明这位老人有高血压并且长期服用强效药物，这两者都可能是导致死亡的原因。然而，这并没有解释雷蒙德的双腿是如何从身上被切断的。刘易斯的一位律师在发表一番离奇的言论时对《芝加哥读者报》（Chicago Reader）称：“杀死某人和在人死后肢解他们是两码事。虽然人在死后被肢解令人厌恶和反感，但这并不是凶杀。”由于只有间接证据将刘易斯与这起犯罪联系起来，该案被驳回，
and he left court a free man. Prosecutor James Bell told reporters that it was, quote, In December 1981, Lewis and his wife Leanne fled the state after police became aware of his involvement in a fraudulent credit card scheme. A warrant was issued for his arrest, but the couple successfully evaded capture, heading northeast to Chicago, where they adopted the aliases Robert and Nancy Richardson, making it one of 17 aliases Lewis adopted over the years. Leanne secured a job working as an accounting clerk at Lakeside Travel Agency before its
他走出法庭，成了一个自由人。检察官詹姆斯·贝尔告诉记者，当时……。1981年12月，在警方发现刘易斯卷入一起欺诈性信用卡计划后，刘易斯和他的妻子利安妮逃离了该州。当局对他的逮捕令已经发出，但这对夫妇成功逃避了抓捕，向东北方向逃往芝加哥，在那里他们采用了罗伯特和南希·理查森的化名，这成了刘易斯多年来使用的17个化名之一。利安妮在湖畔旅行社找到了一份会计文员的工作，三个月后该旅行社
closure three months later. Lewis bounced between temp jobs, leaving the National Bank of Chicago in early September, which prompted the now unemployed couple to relocate again. News of Lewis' fugitive status and connection to the Tylenol case began making headlines and he started penning letters to the Chicago Tribune newspaper to declare his innocence. Earthmarks on the letters revealed he was now living in New York, leading 200 FBI agents to descend on the city in an effort to find him. As it was evident that Lewis was regularly reading the Chicago Tribune, every newsstand
倒闭。刘易斯在临时工作之间辗转，9月上旬离开了芝加哥第一国民银行，这促使当时失业的夫妇再次搬迁。刘易斯作为逃犯的身份以及与泰诺案的联系的新闻开始登上头条，他开始向《芝加哥日报》（Chicago Tribune）写信以声明自己的清白。信件上的邮戳显示他当时住在纽约，导致200名联邦调查局特工涌入该市以寻找他。由于显然刘易斯经常阅读《芝加哥日报》，每一个备有
that stocked the paper was put under 24-hour surveillance, but he never showed up to make a purchase. Agents concluded he must have been reading copies of the newspaper in a library and paid a visit to all the city libraries to inform the staff to be on the lookout for Lewis. On Monday, December 13, a New York public library employee contacted the police when they saw Lewis sitting and reading two books, newspapers of the Southwest and the largest corporations in America, while jotting down the names and addresses of newspaper publications. He was promptly placed under arrest without incident, and his wife turned herself into
该报纸的报摊都受到了24小时的监视，但他从未露面购买。特工们推断他一定是在图书馆里阅读该报的副本，于是造访了该市所有的图书馆，通知工作人员注意刘易斯。12月13日星期一，一名纽约公共图书馆的员工联系了警方，因为他们看到刘易斯坐在那里阅读两本书——《西南部的报纸》和《美国最大的公司》，同时记下报纸出版物的名称和地址。他随即被捕，过程没有发生意外，他的妻子也于不久后向
authorities soon after. Lewis' fingerprints were checked against those on the Johnson & Johnson extortion letter, revealing a match and further cementing his involvement. His handwriting also matched a second extortion letter that had been addressed to President Ronald Reagan in mid-October, which warned that the Tylenol poisonings would continue unless a federal taxation overhaul was conducted. The writer also threatened to fly remote-controlled model airplanes into the White House to scramble secret service telecommunications.
当局自首。经核对，刘易斯的指纹与强生公司勒索信上的指纹相符，这进一步证实了他的涉案程度。他的笔迹也与10月中旬寄给罗纳德·里根总统的第二封勒索信相符，该信警告称，如果不进行联邦税制改革，泰诺中毒事件将继续发生。信件还威胁要将远程控制的模型飞机开进白宫，以干扰特勤局的电信。
It appeared Lewis wrote this second letter in a desperate bid to deflect police attention upon realizing his attempt to frame Frederick Miller McKayhee had only succeeded in bringing attention to himself. Lewis eventually admitted to writing the Johnson & Johnson extortion letter as an act of revenge against Frederick for leaving his wife $500 out of pocket, while also alerting police to the businessman's alleged fraudulent practices. Lewis had stockpiled envelopes from Lakeside Travel Agency, and investigators suspected he had waited for the right crisis to pin on his wife's former boss, striking when the
刘易斯似乎写这第二封信是出于一种绝望的企图，试图转移警方的注意力，因为他意识到自己陷害弗雷德里克·米勒·麦凯希的企图不仅没有成功，反而将注意力引向了自己。刘易斯最终承认写下强生公司勒索信是对弗雷德里克让他的妻子损失50美元的报复，同时也向警方举报了这名商人的涉嫌欺诈行为。刘易斯囤积了来自湖畔旅行社的信封，调查人员怀疑他一直在等待合适的危机来嫁祸给他妻子的前老板，并在芝加哥
Chicago Tylenol murders presented the perfect opportunity. Although Lewis maintained he never intended to collect the million dollars he demanded from Johnson & Johnson, police found evidence to suggest the tech savvy con man knew how to use a computer to transfer money from one bank account to another. He was subsequently charged with attempted extortion. Although he denied having anything to do with the Tylenol murders, arguing that he was in New York at the time the tamperings were believed to have taken place, investigators were not fully convinced.
泰诺谋杀案提供绝佳机会时发动了袭击。尽管刘易斯坚称他从未打算索取他向强生公司索要的一百万美元，但警方发现的证据表明，这位精通技术的骗子懂得如何使用电脑将资金从一个银行账户转到另一个银行账户。他随后被控企图勒索。尽管他否认与泰诺谋杀案有任何关系，并辩称在人们认为发生篡改事件时他人在纽约，但调查人员并未完全信服。
Many noted he bore a resemblance to the man caught on camera in Walgreens, who had been watching Paula Prince as she unknowingly purchased the poisoned capsules, right down to the groomed beard and spectacles. Less than a month after Mary Kellerman had been laid to rest, the Chicago Tribune published a candid piece titled, Living in the Tylenol Killer's Shadow, in which columnist Bob Green addressed the child's killer directly, writing, If you are the Tylenol killer, some of this may matter to you, or it may make no difference at all.
许多人指出，他与沃尔格林药妆店监控拍下的那名男子的长相十分相似，那名男子曾看着宝拉·普林斯毫无防备地购买带毒胶囊，甚至连修剪过的胡须和眼镜都一模一样。在玛丽·凯勒曼入土为安不到一个月后，《芝加哥论坛报》发表了一篇坦诚的文章，题为《生活在泰诺杀手的阴影下》，专栏作家鲍勃·格林在文中直接向这位残害孩子的凶手喊话，写道：“如果你是泰诺杀手，这些事对你来说可能有些意义，或者也可能毫无区别。”
If you are the Tylenol killer, though, you may be harboring just the vaguest curiosity about the people on the other end of your clan, the people who were unfortunate enough to purchase the bottles you had touched. If you are curious, come to a small house on a quiet, winding street in Elk Grove Village, Illinois. The people who live there, Dennis and Gina Kellerman, feel you have already been inside anyway. The piece went on to describe the crushing guilt felt by Gina for purchasing the Tylenol
“然而，如果你是泰诺杀手，你的心中或许会隐约对那些与你素不相识、却不幸买下了你摸过的药瓶的人产生一丝好奇。如果你感到好奇，那就来伊利诺伊州埃尔克格罗夫村一条安静、蜿蜒的小街上的一栋小屋吧。住在那里的人——丹尼斯和吉娜·凯勒曼——觉得你无论如何都已经潜入过他们的家了。”文章接着描述了吉娜因购买了泰诺
that ended up taking her daughter's life. Bob Green explained, If you are the Tylenol killer, you should know one more thing. Mary's mother can't have any more children. Mary was her only baby. You might be interested in knowing that Mary was born one month premature, and that as she entered the world, her mother was scared because she was not crying. But the doctor smiled and said,
而最终夺走女儿生命而感到那种无以复加的内疚。鲍勃·格林解释道：“如果你是泰诺杀手，你还应该知道一件事。玛丽的母亲再也不能生孩子了。玛丽是她唯一的宝贝。你或许会有兴趣知道，玛丽早产了一个月，当她来到这个世界时，她的母亲曾感到害怕，因为她没有哭。但医生微笑着说：”
It's alright, she's only sleeping. And she was. She was a quiet child, and because the Kellermans knew she would be their only child, she was especially precious to them. Green detailed how the Kellermans had considered themselves overprotective of their only child, who had to be home by dark and to call frequently to let them know she was alright. Quote, They thought they knew about every danger that could possibly touch Mary, but they didn't
“‘没关系，她只是在睡觉。’她确实在睡。她是个安静的孩子，正因为凯勒曼夫妇知道她将是他们唯一的孩子，所以她对他们而言格外珍贵。”格林详细描述了凯勒曼夫妇如何认为自己对这个唯一的孩子过于保护，她必须在天黑前回家，并经常打电话让他们知道自己平安无事。引文：“他们以为自己了解所有可能伤害到玛丽的危险，但他们却不
know about you. Bob Green's column included the following statement to Mary's killer. If you are wondering whether Mary's parents talk about you, you don't have to wonder any more. They do. You have never been in their house, and yet they cannot walk into a room without feeling you are there. You don't know them, but you have changed their lives forever.
了解你。”鲍勃·格林专栏中包含了致玛丽杀手的以下声明：“如果你在猜想玛丽的父母是否在谈论你，你大可不必再猜了。他们确实在谈论。你从未去过他们的家，然而他们走入任何一个房间，都无法不觉得你就在那里。你不认识他们，但你已经彻底改变了他们的人生。”
They feel as if they can't get away from you. As it is, you should know, Mary's parents are too shattered even to visit the cemetery. Mary is buried at St. Michael the Archangel in nearby Palatine, Illinois, and they wish they could go to her grave, but they can't. The herd is too deep, and you are keeping them even from that. Even with the full permission of the Kellerman family, Bob Green's emotional peace had actually been commissioned by the Tylenol Task Force in the hopes that would compel the unknown killer to visit Mary's grave.
“他们觉得仿佛无法逃脱你的魔掌。既然如此，你应该知道，玛丽的父母悲痛欲绝，甚至无法去墓地凭吊。玛丽安葬在伊利诺伊州帕拉丁市附近的圣米迦勒大天使公墓，他们多么希望能去她的墓前，但他们去不了。伤痛太深了，而你甚至连这一点都剥夺了。”即便在得到凯勒曼夫妇的全力许可下，鲍勃·格林这篇动情的文章实际上是由泰诺专案组委托撰写的，希望以此迫使未知的凶手去拜访玛丽的墓地。
After the column was published, her headstone was put under 24-hour covert surveillance for several months, but the killer did not appear. In the month following the Chicago Tylenol murders, hundreds of copycat incidents emerged across America, with the Food and Drug Administration tallying more than 270 occurrences of product tampering. People across the country fell ill after consuming pills tainted with everything from rat poison to hydrochloric acid. On Halloween, parents reported finding sharp pins concealed in candy, forcing some communities
在该专栏发表后，她的墓碑连续几个月受到24小时的秘密监视，但凶手并未出现。在芝加哥泰诺谋杀案发生后的一个月里，全美各地涌现出数百起模仿作案事件，美国食品药品监督管理局统计的产品篡改事件超过270起。全国各地的人们在服用了从老鼠药到盐酸等各种毒物污染的药丸后纷纷生病。万圣节期间，父母们报告称在糖果中发现了藏匿的尖头别针，迫使一些社区
to ban trickle-treating altogether. Tylenol returned to store shelves just over a month following the murders, after Johnson and Johnson developed triple-sealed tamper-proof packaging and invented the Caplet, a tablet coated with gelatin that was easy to swallow but harder to contaminate. These innovative concepts became the global industry standard and were soon implemented by other companies involved in the production of medicine and other consumables. Eight months after James Lewis sent the fraudulent letter to Johnson and Johnson, he was convicted of extortion and sentenced to serve 20 years in federal prison.
彻底禁止了不给糖就捣蛋的活动。在强生公司开发出三重密封防篡改包装并发明了卡普莱特（Caplet，一种涂有明胶、易于吞咽但更难被污染的药片）之后，泰诺在谋杀案发生一个多月后重新回到了商店货架上。这些创新概念成为了全球行业标准，并很快被其他从事药品和其他消费品生产的公司所采用。在詹姆斯·刘易斯向强生公司发送欺诈信八个月后，他被裁定犯有勒索罪，并被判处在联邦监狱服刑20年。
Although he remained a suspect in the Tylenol murders, he was just one of 400 people of interest who were extensively investigated for their possible involvement. Among them was 48-year-old Roger Arnold, a dockhand who worked for a Jewel Food's warehouse west of Chicago, the supermarket chain that sold the poisoned Tylenol to Adam Janus and Gina Kellerman. In early October 1982, Arnold was drinking at a bar called Lilies when he started telling stories about killing people with cyanide. The bar's owner, Marty Sinclair, overheard the remarks and contacted authorities.
尽管他依然是泰诺谋杀案的嫌疑人之一，但他只是被广泛调查其可能涉案的400名受关注人员之一。其中包括48岁的罗杰·阿诺德，他是一名码头工人，在芝加哥以西的一家杰维尔食品公司（Jewel Food's）仓库工作——正是这家连锁超市将带毒的泰诺卖给了亚当·扬尼斯和吉娜·凯勒曼。1982年10月上旬，阿诺德在一家名为“莉莉丝”的酒吧喝酒时，开始吹嘘用氰化物杀人的故事。酒吧老板马蒂·辛克莱无意中听到了这些言论，并联系了当局。
The police conducted a search of Arnold's Southside apartment and uncovered a bag of chemical powder, funnels, beakers, test tubes, four unlicensed firearms, how-to crime manuals and copies of Soldier of Fortune magazine. Arnold was arrested and questioned for three days in relation to the Chicago Tylenol murders, during which he professed his innocence and told officers, I'd like to be in on the homicide of the guy that turned me in for what he did to me. The powder found in Arnold's apartment was determined to be potassium carbonate, a relatively harmless salt used in the production of glass and soap.
警方搜查了阿诺德位于南区的公寓，发现了一包化学粉末、漏斗、烧杯、试管、四支无证枪支、《犯罪实操手册》以及《雇佣兵》杂志的副本。阿诺德因芝加哥泰诺谋杀案被捕并接受了三天审讯，在此期间他坚称自己无辜，并对警官们说：“我很想亲自干掉那个把我供出来、为他对我所做的事负责的人。”在阿诺德公寓里发现的粉末经测定是碳酸钾，这是一种无害的盐，常用于玻璃和肥皂的生产。
He refused to say what the chemicals were used for but asserted it was for nothing illegal. He was ultimately released without charge, but the notoriety of having been considered a suspect in the case took a huge toll on his reputation. Colleagues gave him the unwanted nickname Tylenol Kid and his local community kept their distance eyeing him with constant suspicion. Overwhelmed by the profoundly negative impact the single tip-off had on his life, Arnold sought revenge on the person who gave his name to the police. Eight months later, on the night of June 17, 1983, he drove to Lily's bar and confronted
他拒绝透露这些化学品的用途，但坚称绝非用于任何非法勾当。他最终被无罪释放，但曾被列为该案嫌疑人的恶名对他的声誉造成了沉重打击。同事们给他起了个不受欢迎的外号叫“泰诺小子”，当地社区也对他保持距离，带着持续的怀疑注视着他。单一线索对他的生活产生了如此深远的负面影响，这让他不堪重负，阿诺德决定向那个把他的名字提供给警方的人报复。八个月后的1983年6月17日夜晚，他驱车前往莉莉丝酒吧，与
the owner Marty Sinclair, telling him, You turned me in, before shooting him at point blank range. However, in a case of mistaken identity, Arnold had not shot Marty Sinclair at all. He had executed 46-year-old father of three, Johnston Nisha, who happened to closely resemble Marty. Arnold was convicted of second-degree murder and sentenced to 30 years in prison, serving only 15. Prior to his death in 2008, he expressed remorse at his botched act of revenge, remarking,
老板马蒂·辛克莱对质，对他说：“是你把我供出来的，”随即便在近距离内开枪击中了对方。然而，由于认错人，阿诺德根本没有射杀马蒂·辛克莱。他处决的是46岁、育有三个孩子的父亲约翰斯顿·尼沙，此人恰好长得很像马蒂。阿诺德被裁定犯有二级谋杀罪，被判处30年监禁，实际仅服刑15年。在2008年去世之前，他表达了对自己那次笨拙报复行为的悔意，评论道：
I killed a man, a perfectly innocent person, I had choices, I could have walked away. As the Chicago Tylenol Murders investigation continued, a dossier listing potential persons of interest grew to 10,000 names. A special computer program was created to collate the hundreds of reports taken by the various police departments, which would alert officers to important discoveries, like when an individual was mentioned in multiple reports, or a common thread was recognized. Despite these efforts, with no direct connection between the victims and no motive, crime scene, or useful evidence, investigative options were limited.
“我杀了一个人，一个完全无辜的人，我本有选择，我本可以一走了之。”随着芝加哥泰诺谋杀案调查的继续，潜在嫌疑人档案上的名字增加到了10,000个。一个特殊的计算机程序被创建出来，用于整理各个警察局收到的数百份报告，该程序将在发现重要线索时提醒警官，例如当某个人在多份报告中被提及，或识别出共同的线索时。尽管付出了这些努力，但在受害者之间没有直接联系、且没有动机、犯罪现场或有用证据的情况下，调查手段非常有限。
FBI criminal behavior specialists were given the task of developing a psychological profile of the killer, and although they couldn't come up with a unanimous result, they agreed that the perpetrator was likely male, aged in his 20s or 30s, well above average intelligence, meticulous in his personal habits, and a loner who may hold a disdain for women. The specialists were perplexed to discover that the perpetrator hadn't left behind a message or any type of indicator to draw conclusions from, making it particularly difficult to establish their rationale. One psychologist concluded that the killer likely believed they had a perfectly good
联邦调查局的犯罪行为专家受命为凶手建立心理侧写，尽管他们未能得出一致的结论，但他们一致认为作案者很可能是男性，年龄在20多岁到30多岁之间，智力远高于平均水平，个人习惯一丝不苟，是一个可能对女性抱有蔑视的独行者。令专家们感到困惑的是，作案者没有留下任何信息或任何可供推断的指标，这使得确定其作案动机变得异常困难。一位心理学家得出结论，凶手可能认为自己有一套完美的理由
reason for committing the crimes, but might never justify it to anyone else. It was his opinion that normal investigative procedures were not going to work in this situation, and that the person responsible was likely never going to be found. Nevertheless, politicians and senior police personnel continued to mask the dire status of the investigation by implying progress was being made. Frustrated by these false claims, Illinois police called a press conference to admit they knew nothing more now than they did when the first murders took place. These comments caused an immediate backlash, and when Chicago police superintendent Richard
来实施这些罪行，但可能永远不会向任何人解释。他的观点是，常规的调查程序在这种情况下行不通，负责此案的人很可能永远也找不到了。尽管如此，政界人士和高级警务人员仍继续掩饰调查的严峻现状，暗示案件取得了进展。对这些虚假声明感到愤怒的伊利诺伊州警方召开了一场新闻发布会，承认他们现在所知道的并不比第一起谋杀案发生时多。这些言论引起了立即的反弹，当芝加哥警察局长理查德·
Brizak was asked by his superiors to justify the remarks, he answered, By November 1982, the Tylenol task force had been reduced from 115 investigators to approximately 50, and by March the following year, the police tip line had been disconnected. From the one year anniversary of the murders arrived, the task force had been scaled down further to a team of just 10 full-time state and federal agents. That month, Illinois criminal investigations commander Thomas Shump told the Chicago Tribune that efforts were still underway to re-examine all the data collected over the previous year. Files were constantly being shifted between investigators in the hopes a fresh pair of
布里扎克被上级要求为这些言论辩护时，他回答道……。到1982年11月，泰诺专案组的调查人员从115人缩减至约50人，到次年3月，警方热线电话也被切断了。谋杀案一周年纪念日到来时，专案组进一步缩减为一个仅有10名全职州和联邦特工的小组。当月，伊利诺伊州刑事调查指挥官托马斯·舒姆告诉《芝加哥论坛报》，重新审查过去一年收集的所有数据的努力仍在进行中。文件不断在调查人员之间流转，希望换一双
eyes would pick up on something that had been missed. Shump was surprised the case had not been solved sooner, stating, I applied my best people to this case. These are guys used to success, and early on, we all thought we were going to be successful this time too. We were full of energy, convinced that it was just a matter of hard work, painstaking research and making our own breaks. When you apply the kind of resources we used, you solve 99% of the cases.
全新的眼睛能够发现之前被忽略的线索。舒姆对该案未能更快侦破感到惊讶，他表示：“我把最优秀的人手安排到了这个案子上。这些人都是习惯了成功的人，早期的时候，我们都以为这次我们也会成功。我们充满活力，坚信这不过是苦干、细致研究以及靠我们自己打破僵局的问题。当你投入我们所使用的这种资源时，99%的案件都能侦破。”
That year, a bill was passed by the US Congress titled the Tylenol Bill, making it a federal crime to tamper with consumer products. The penalty for tampering aimed at hurting the reputation of a business included a $10,000 fine and up to three years in prison. Those convicted of meddling with products and endangering consumers' lives or safety faced up to a $100,000 fine and a life sentence. These new laws were put into practice just three years later, when two people in Washington State died after consuming over-the-counter excedrin pain relief capsules laced with cyanide.
那年，美国国会通过了一项名为《泰诺法案》的法案，将篡改消费品的行为定为联邦重罪。针对旨在损害企业声誉的篡改行为的惩罚包括1万美元罚款和最高3年监禁。那些因干预产品而危及消费者生命安全的罪犯则面临高达10万美元的罚款和终身监禁。这些新法律在仅仅三年后就被付诸实践——当时华盛顿州有两人在食用了掺有氰化物的非处方扑热息痛（Excedrin）止痛胶囊后死亡。
This crime, covered in episode 93 of Case File, was unrelated to but directly inspired by the Chicago Tylenol murders. The mystery endured over the following years, with millions of dollars and investigative hours amounting to very little advancement and no major breakthroughs. Nine years after the tragedy, the families of the seven victims initiated a legal action against Johnson and Johnson, alleging that product tampering was a well-known problem before the murders and that the company should have taken steps to safeguard their product. In May 1991, an out-of-court settlement was reached after three days of negotiation, with
这起案件在《档案》第93集中有详细报道，与芝加哥泰诺谋杀案没有直接关系，但直接受其启发。随后的几年里，这个谜团一直没有解开，数百万美元和无数的调查工时换来的却是微乎其微的进展和没有重大突破。悲剧发生九年之后，七名受害者的家属对强生公司提起了法律诉讼，指控产品篡改在谋杀案发生前就是一个众所周知的问题，该公司本应采取措施保障其产品的安全。1991年5月，经过三天的谈判，双方达成了庭外和解，
the exact terms and dollar amounts sealed by a court order. The plaintiffs were pleased with the result, as the compensation included provision for the college education of the eight children whose parents died in the poisonings. Some experts believed the company chose to forgo a trial, as even an exorbitant financial settlement was preferable over the potential brand damage that would result from litigation. At Johnson & Johnson spokesperson maintained the company had nothing to do with the poisonings and was just another victim of the crime, stating, While there is no way that we could have anticipated a criminal tampering with our product or prevented
确切的条款和美元金额被法院命令密封。原告对结果感到满意，因为赔偿金包括为在毒杀事件中父母双亡的八名儿童提供大学教育的费用。一些专家认为，该公司选择放弃庭审，因为即使是巨额的财务和解，也比诉讼可能带来的品牌损害要好。强生公司的一位发言人坚称，该公司与这起毒杀事件毫无关系，只是这起犯罪的又一个受害者，他表示：虽然我们不可能预料到会有人对我们的产品进行蓄意篡改或阻止
it, we wanted to do something for these families and finally put this tragic event behind us. During his imprisonment for extortion, Tylenol Murders suspect James Lewis met with U.S. Attorney Jeremy Margolis to volunteer his services to help solve the crime. During the pair's meetings, Lewis provided hundreds of pages of manuscripts, diagrams and theories as to how the killings were carried out. In one sketch, he depicted how cyanide could be inserted into capsules, but captioned it with the statement, drawn on speculation at the request of Assistant U.S. Attorney Jeremy D. Margolis to ensure it could not be treated as a confession.
它发生，但我们想为这些家庭做点什么，并最终把这个悲惨的事件抛在脑后。在因敲诈勒索入狱期间，泰诺谋杀案嫌疑人詹姆斯·刘易斯会见了美国检察官杰里米·马尔戈利斯，主动提出协助破案。在两人的会面中，刘易斯提供了数百页的手稿、图表和关于凶杀案是如何实施的理论。在一张草稿中，他描绘了如何将氰化物塞进胶囊，但他在标题中写道，这是应美国助理检察官杰里米·D·马尔戈利斯的要求进行的猜测，以确保它不会被视为供词。
An article in the Chicago Reader newspaper titled, A Bitter Pill, explained, In that drawing, Lewis delineates in great detail how the killer might have used an ordinary breadboard to turn an ordinary pain reliever into an agent of death. The poisoner could drill holes in the board, place separated, empty capsule halves into the holes, fill them with cyanide and scrape off the excess with a knife, recap the capsules and put them back into their original containers. The entire process could be performed in a car at the store's parking lot, allowing the killer to buy the Tylenol, contaminate the capsules and return the bottle to the
《芝加哥读者报》上的一篇题为《苦涩的药丸》的文章解释说：在这幅画中，刘易斯详细描述了凶手如何利用一块普通的切菜板将一种普通的止痛药变成杀人工具。下毒者可以在木板上钻洞，把分离的空胶囊的一半放进洞里，用氰化物填满它们，用刀刮掉多余的部分，重新合上胶囊并把它们放回原包装里。整个过程可以在商店停车场的一辆汽车里完成，让凶手买下泰诺，污染胶囊并将瓶子放回
shelf minutes later. Nothing would appear out of the ordinary because the bottle would still bear the price tags and other identifying marks of that particular store. Despite all the information Lewis provided, he never directly implicated himself in the crimes. In 1995, after serving 13 years of his 20-year prison sentence, he was released on parole. Nine years later, in 2004, he was charged with rape, kidnapping and other offences in relation to the attack of a woman in his apartment building.
几分钟后的货架上。一切看起来都很正常，因为瓶子上仍然带有该特定商店的价格标签和其他识别标志。尽管刘易斯提供了所有这些信息，但他从未直接将自己牵连到这些罪行中。1995年，在服完20年刑期的13年后，他获得假释出狱。九年后的2004年，他因涉嫌在其公寓大楼内袭击一名女性而被指控犯有强奸、绑架和其他罪行。
On the day this trial was due to commence in July 2007, the District Attorney's Office announced that they were dropping the charges because the victim refused to testify. On the 25th anniversary of the Chicago Tylenol murders in September 2007, James Lewis published a post on his web design and programming business website, Cyber Lewis, which read, In a quarter of a century, I have not been able to escape the Tylenol man label. A Google search of James Lewis Tylenol yields over 240,000 documents and the list is growing. After 25 years of cringing in fear, I am tired of hiding in silence. I will not run and tired anymore.
在2007年7月本应开庭审判的那天，地方检察官办公室宣布撤销指控，因为受害者拒绝作证。在2007年9月芝加哥泰诺谋杀案25周年之际，詹姆斯·刘易斯在他的网页设计和编程业务网站Cyber Lewis上发表了一篇帖子，上面写着：四分之一个世纪以来，我一直无法摆脱泰诺男的标签。在谷歌上搜索詹姆斯·刘易斯·泰诺会产生超过24万份文档，而且这个数字还在增长。在经历了25年的战战兢兢之后，我厌倦了在沉默中躲藏。我不会再逃跑和厌倦了。
I will now face this controversy head on. After 25 years, the Tylenol murders remain unsolved. I have lived a long, bizarre life and I have seen a lot, yet I am literate and lucid enough to view and describe, compare and contrast hugely diverse worlds, cultures and topics without a moment of boredom or with an eye to professionalism, demographics and marketability, plus ears and heart sensitive to good taste and victim's feelings. Two years later, in early 2009, Department of Justice investigators stated publicly that although they didn't have enough evidence to charge James Lewis, they were confident
我现在将正面迎接这场争议。25年过去了，泰诺谋杀案仍然没有破案。我过着漫长而诡异的生活，见识过很多东西，但我有足够的文化素养和清醒的头脑去观察、描述、比较和对比截然不同的世界、文化和主题，而不会感到一丝厌烦，也不会过于关注专业性、人口统计学和适销性，同时我的耳朵和内心对好品味和受害者的感受保持敏感。两年后，即2009年初，美国司法部调查人员公开表示，虽然他们没有足够的证据起诉詹姆斯·刘易斯，但他们确信
he was responsible for the Tylenol murders. In February 2009, federal investigators executed a search warrant at Lewis' first floor apartment in Cambridge, Massachusetts, where he had lived since his release from prison in 1995. After searching the residence and a nearby storage facility, five boxes full of evidence and a late model Macintosh computer were seized. Theresa Janus' brother, Walter, said he hoped the search would finally provide police with enough information to lead to an arrest, especially considering his father was about to celebrate his 80th birthday and longed to see his daughter's killer behind bars.
他对泰诺谋杀案负有责任。2009年2月，联邦调查人员对刘易斯位于马萨诸塞州剑桥市一楼的公寓执行了搜查令，自1995年出狱以来他一直住在那里。在搜查了该住所和附近的储藏设施后，查获了五箱证据和一台晚期的麦金塔电脑。特雷莎·亚努斯的弟弟沃尔特说，他希望这次搜查最终能为警方提供足够的信息以实施逮捕，考虑到他的父亲即将庆祝80岁生日，渴望看到杀害他女儿的凶手锒铛入狱。
Walter said, They always told us that cases like this never go into the cold file, that they just don't always get the attention they deserve. All we can do is hope. We'd like to bring it to closure. The search failed to uncover any evidence to affect an arrest, but investigators were still unwilling to rule Lewis out as a suspect. In January 2010, both he and his wife were ordered to submit DNA samples and fingerprints
沃尔特说：他们总是告诉我们，像这样的案件永远不会进入积压档案，只是它们并没有总是得到应得的关注。我们能做的只有希望。我们希望能有个了结。搜查未能发现任何足以实施逮捕的证据，但调查人员仍然不愿排除刘易斯作为嫌疑人的可能。2010年1月，他和他妻子都被下令提交DNA样本和指纹
to authorities after a closed-door court hearing, though these submissions also did not lead to his arrest. Lewis maintained he was just a scapegoat for incompetent police who were unable to find the real Tylenol killer, but others remained convinced of his guilt, with Chicago attorney Anton Velukas stating, I believe that the evidence which was out there would lead a rational person to conclude that Lewis was in fact the murderer. However, other investigators were less convinced, surmising Lewis was just a schemer who relished
在闭门听证会后交给当局，不过这些提交也没有导致他被捕。刘易斯坚称自己只是无能警方的替罪羊，警方找不到真正的泰诺凶手，但其他人仍然坚信他有罪，芝加哥律师安东·维卢卡斯表示：我相信现有的证据会得出一个理性的结论，即刘易斯实际上就是凶手。然而，其他调查人员则没有那么确信，他们推测刘易斯只是一个渴望
the attention, as was evident when he self-published an e-book titled, Poison, a Doctor's Dilemma, a fictional thriller about a mass catastrophe in a mid-western city. In 2012, Lifestyle Publication Chicago magazine interviewed several people involved in the Tylenol murder case to discuss their theories about the long-standing mystery 30 years on. One detective expressed his opinion that James Lewis was not involved in any way, as the extensive investigation had revealed no direct connections. Attorney General Ty Farner disputed this, saying, Do I think James Lewis was involved?
关注的阴谋家，正如他自费出版了一本名为《毒药：医生的困境》的电子书时所明显看出的那样，这是一部关于中西部城市大规模灾难的虚构惊悚片。2012年，生活方式出版物《芝加哥》杂志采访了几位参与泰诺谋杀案的人，讨论了他们对30年后这个长期未解之谜的看法。一位侦探表达了他的观点，即詹姆斯·刘易斯没有以任何方式参与其中，因为广泛的调查没有显示出任何直接联系。总检察长泰·法纳尔对此提出了异议，他说：我认为詹姆斯·刘易斯参与了吗？
I did, and I do. But we could never put him in the city, in the places, at the right time. This was mirrored by Chicago Police Department Lieutenant August LaCalla, who worked in the violent crime squad during the Tylenol murders. He said, Lewis is a con man, and he'll do anything to get to his goal. I really believed he might have killed somebody, but they couldn't put anything on him. Lewis remained in the large pool of suspects, which at one point included infamous unabomber
我曾经这样认为，现在也这样认为。但我们从来没能把他放在那个城市里、那些地方、在正确的时间。芝加哥警察局中尉奥古斯特·拉卡拉也表达了同样的看法，他在泰诺谋杀案期间曾在暴力犯罪小队工作。他说：刘易斯是个骗子，为了达到目的他什么都做得出来。我真的相信他可能杀过人，但他们拿他没办法。刘易斯仍然留在庞大的嫌疑人池中，其中一度包括声名狼藉的大学炸弹客
Ted Kaczynski. Kaczynski's first four acts of domestic terrorism occurred in the Chicago area, and he occasionally stayed at his parents' home in Lombard, Illinois. He denied any involvement in the crime, and investigators weren't fully convinced, as it didn't entirely fit his MO. When the Chicago Tylenol murders occurred in 1982, there was an almost immediate impact on Wall Street, with Johnson & Johnson's $5.4 billion stock plummeting, and their market share collapsing from 35% to 8%.
泰德·卡钦斯基。卡钦斯基的前四起国内恐怖主义行动发生在芝加哥地区，他偶尔会住在位于伊利诺伊州伦巴рд的父母家中。他否认参与了这起犯罪，调查人员也没有完全信服，因为这并不完全符合他的作案手法。1982年芝加哥泰诺谋杀案发生时，对华尔街产生了几乎立竿见影的影响，强生公司价值54亿美元的股票暴跌，其市场份额从35%骤降至8%。
Nevertheless, the company swift actions to contain the emergency garnered praise from the media and the public. A Washington Post newspaper article published the month following the deaths stated, Johnson & Johnson has effectively demonstrated how a major business ought to handle a disaster. After investing more than $100 million, Johnson & Johnson relaunched the Tylenol brand and regained a 30% share of the market, before resuming its number one spot as America's top-selling over-the-counter pain reliever. In 2003, Fortune magazine named the company's then-CEO James Burke as one of history's
尽管如此，该公司为遏制紧急情况而采取的迅速行动赢得了媒体和公众的赞誉。在死亡事件发生后一个月发表的一篇《华盛顿邮报》文章指出：强生公司有效地展示了一家大企业应该如何处理灾难。在投资超过1.04亿美元之后，强生公司重新推出了泰诺品牌，并重新获得了30%的市场份额，随后恢复了其作为美国最畅销的非处方止痛药的第一名地位。2003年，《财富》杂志将该公司当时的首席执行官詹姆斯·伯克评为历史上
10 greatest CEOs for his handling of the crisis. Skeptics and cynics have since viewed the company with a far more critical eye. As Johnson & Johnson initially lied about storing cyanide at their Tylenol manufacturing facilities, many theorists believe the company was somehow responsible for the contamination and went to great lengths to cover it up by encouraging the lone-temporal theory. To this day, the Chicago Tylenol murders remains one of the most notorious unsolved crimes in American history. Crimes remain perplexed by the unknown killer, whose motive remains a point of contention.
凭借对危机的处理，位列10大杰出CEO之一。从那以后，怀疑论者和讽刺者以更加批判的眼光看待该公司。由于强生公司最初对在其泰诺制造设施中储存氰化物一事撒谎，许多理论家认为该公司不知何故对污染负有责任，并通过鼓励孤立的临时理论来竭力掩盖真相。直到今天，芝加哥泰诺谋杀案仍然是美国历史上最臭名昭著的未破悬案之一。对于动机仍然存在争议的未知凶手，犯罪人员仍然感到困惑。
Investigators are uncertain whether the crimes were a meticulously orchestrated and targeted murder or an act of domestic terrorism. James Zagel, former director of the Illinois Department of Law Enforcement, has spoken of his hope that the case will one day be solved, noting, We've solved other crimes a year, two years, 20 years afterwards, while I have not given up hope or lost optimism. Sometimes you have to admit you've lost, but that's not the case with the Tylenol deaths. Authorities maintain the case is still active.
调查人员不确定这些犯罪是精心策划和有针对性的谋杀，还是一起国内恐怖主义行为。伊利诺伊州执法局前局长詹姆斯·扎盖尔曾表示希望这个案件有一天能水落石出，他指出：我们在一年、两年、20年后破获了其他案件，我并没有放弃希望或失去乐观。有时你必须承认你输了，但泰诺死亡案并非如此。当局坚称此案仍在调查中。
The families of the victims live on without justice. Six months after the murders, Mary Reiner's husband, Ed, told reporters that the couple's two-year-old son would look at photographs of his mother and ask when she was coming home. Ed explained, I tell him she's in heaven now. I still don't understand why something like this happened, and I don't think I ever will. On the crime's one-year anniversary, Teresa Janus' mother, Helen, explained that while their house used to be full of life and parties, it was now empty.
受害者的家属在没有得到正义的情况下继续生活。谋杀案发生六个月后，玛丽·赖纳（Mary Reiner）的丈夫埃德（Ed）对记者说，这对夫妇两岁的儿子会看着他母亲的照片，问她什么时候回家。埃德解释说：“我告诉他她现在在天堂。我仍然不明白为什么会发生这样的事情，我想我永远也不会明白。”在案件发生一周年之际，特蕾莎·雅努斯（Teresa Janus）的母亲海伦（Helen）解释说，虽然他们的房子过去总是充满生机和聚会，但现在却空无一人。
She kept a shrine of photographs to remember her daughter and son-in-law, remarking, It always hurts inside. Two decades on, Mary Kellerman's grandmother, Patricia, spoke of the continuing grief, stating, It's still devastating to the family, especially when they haven't caught who did it. I'm sure a lot of people have forgotten it, but I can tell you that the families still remember. This sentiment was shared by Joseph Janus, who lost two of his brothers to the Tylenol poisonings, and said,
她保留了一个照片神龛来缅怀她的女儿和女婿，并评论道：“内心总是隐隐作痛。”二十年后，玛丽·凯勒曼（Mary Kellerman）的祖母帕特里夏（Patricia）谈到了持续的悲伤，她表示：“这对家庭来说仍然是毁灭性的打击，尤其是当他们还没抓到凶手的时候。我确信很多人已经把它忘了，但我可以告诉你，家属们仍然记得。”约瑟夫·雅努斯（Joseph Janus）也有同感，他在泰诺中毒事件中失去了两个兄弟，他说：
It never goes away. It stays in your chest. In an interview with the Chicago Tribune in 2009, Mary McFarlane's brother Eliason explained how he can no longer stomach even looking at a box of Tylenol. Quote, I now think of Mary not being here, what she's missing. Her son's growing up, a granddaughter being born, a daughter-in-law she would have loved. A colleague of Paula Prince remembered her as a vivacious woman with a gorgeous smile, and spoke of the unknown killer.
“这永远不会消失。它一直压在你的胸口。”在2009年接受《芝加哥论坛报》采访时，玛丽·麦克法兰（Mary McFarlane）的兄弟埃利森（Eliason）解释了他如何再也无法忍受看一眼泰诺盒子。引述如下：“我现在想到的是玛丽不在这里，她错过了什么。她儿子的成长，孙女的出生，一个她本会疼爱的儿媳。”宝拉·普林斯（Paula Prince）的一位同事回忆她是一个充满活力、笑容灿烂的女性，并谈到了那个未知的凶手。
Quote, that guy stole all her dreams, her life, her future. He just destroyed it all. Just poof, one pill. What makes a man do something like that? In the early days of the Tylenol investigation, Illinois criminal investigation commander Thomas Shump told the Chicago Tribune, The first thing you look for in any murder is motivation. In 99% of the cases, it's relatively easy.
引述如下：“那家伙偷走了她所有的梦想、她的人生、她的未来。他把这一切都毁了。就这样，砰，一颗药丸。是什么让一个男人做出这样的事？”在泰诺案调查的早期，伊利诺伊州刑事调查指挥官托马斯·舒姆普（Thomas Shump）对《芝加哥论坛报》说：“在任何谋杀案中，你首先寻找的是动机。在99%的案件中，这相对容易。”
A husband, wife, lover, boyfriend is involved, or narcotics are involved, and you are on your way to solving it. But with Tylenol, there was never a message left behind. It's so important to know why, what was the message, what was the reason. With Tylenol, not only can't we say who, we can't even say what, or why. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
丈夫、妻子、情夫、男友卷入其中，或者与毒品有关，你就在破案的路上了。但在泰诺案中，从来没有留下过任何信息。知道为什么、信息是什么、原因是什么，这是非常重要的。对于泰诺案，我们不仅说不出是谁，甚至连是什么或为什么都说不出。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。